millions of years ago when humans and
gods didn't exist in the universe there
lived a supernatural entity called the
Titans they were the most powerful and
divine creatures but their reign was
ended by their own Sons Zeus Poseidon
and Hades the oldest brother Zeus was
the smartest of the lot he convinced his
brother Hades to create a beast with his
powers a beast so strong and evil that
it could defeat their parents from Hades
flesh the Unspeakable horror of Kraken
was born who ended the Titans and gave
immense power to the brothers during the
distribution of their parents Powers
Zeus gets to be the god of the heavens
and Poseidon gets to be the god of the
sea but Hades is tricked by Zeus into
being the bearer of the trauma and
sadness of the underworld next Zeus
creates humans whose prayers keep him
and other gods Immortal at the same time
Hades uses humans fear to gain Powers
however as time passes war and suffering
multiply in the world that Zeus once
thought was perfect people start
questioning why their father would put
them through such hell and their trust
in God starts to fade hinting towards a
terrifying thought of a battle between
gods and The Mortals Mortals would be
doomed for sure oh this movie's about
that all right let's see what happens
the scene changes to a poor fishing man
sailing through a dangerous sea storm
far away in the dead of the sea he sees
a coffin-like box floating towards him
he somehow fishes it into his boat and
comes across a horrifying sight inside
the coffin is the corpse of a mother
holding her newborn baby who is
fortunately still alive the fisherman
takes the baby boy into his arms and
swears to protect and feed him somewhere
nearby a mysterious woman is watching
them intensely when the kid grows up to
be a teen the fisherman's wife gets
pregnant while the boy is afraid his
father will forget him after holding his
own blood in his arms he is assured that
their bond is stronger than any relation
by Blood time passes and the kid one day
becomes a brave fisherman named Perseus
he has a little sister who he loves more
than anything in the world and the
loving family of four by now human
Rebellion Against The Gods has
multiplied several Nations have burned
sacred statues LED forces to Olympus and
stopped praying altogether all of which
have posed a great threat to the lives
of the Immortals one afternoon per with
his family is on his boat traveling a
long way to fish however even after
hours of trying their nets come back
empty his father blames the gods for
punishing them with hunger and
starvation while his mother claims that
at least they are blessed with life
Perseus stands neutral to the
conversation as his only concern is his
starving family suddenly they see a
massive statue of Zeus being attacked by
some men they are soldiers of the
country named Argos whose King had
ordered them to knock down the statue
after the massive art of concrete Falls
there is a moment of silence before
something starts moving in the water all
of a sudden bat-like humanoids soar up
to the sky and kill the soldiers one
after another Perseus and his family
watch in horror too afraid to move and
grab the bird's attention when the
killings stop the birds merge into one
and transform into Hades the god of the
underworld himself there to punish the
foolish who dared to disrespect his
brother Hades his eyes land upon the
boat Perseus is he pushes it with a
slight Force sending the entire family
into the sea Perseus tries his best to
get his loved ones out but in the end he
is the only Survivor in the following
scene a rescue team from Argos arrives
and brings Perseus to the Palace
although he was the only surviving one
from the fight the king sees it as a
victory and orders his men to celebrate
the queen going along with her husband
calls herself the God and insults Zeus
with her harsh judgment before she knows
it the terrifying Hades appears in front
of them and sucks the beauty and youth
out of her Perseus tries foolishly to
attack him angered about his family's
death but a woman stops him since human
fear feeds Hades his power he doesn't
want to Simply kill everyone in the
palace instead he gives them a choice
they offer their beautiful princess as a
sacrifice to him or the Unspeakable
horror of Kraken will be freed upon
Argos after announcing that the King has
the next 10 days to decide Hades turns
towards Perseus he frees for a second
and calls him the son of Zeus before
disappearing Perseus doesn't know what
to make of his words but everyone else
figures out that he is a demigod The
Offspring of a God and a human he is
thrown in prison and tortured in hopes
that he will find a way to save the city
the kind-hearted princess tries to stop
the soldiers she is happily ready to
sacrifice her life if it means that her
people will get to live but the king
doesn't want that in the next scene a
woman is allowed to meet Perseus in
prison she is the same mysterious woman
who is around when the fisherman found
Perseus and the same one who stopped him
from attacking Hades earlier she
introduces herself as IO a mortal who
once refused the advancement of a God
and was cursed to never age or die it
hardly seems like a curse but IO
explains that she had to watch all of
her loved ones die and live on without
them since she has been alive for almost
a thousand years she knows everything
about Perseus his mother and the story
of how they ended up in the sea several
years ago the Rebellion king of country
led a large army towards Olympus
angering the gods Zeus Who Loved humans
as his own didn't want to kill them so
he thought of making an example of the
King instead disguised as the King Zeus
went to the queen and made love to her
when the king returned from the battle
he found his wife impregnated by his
worst enemy burning with rage he put her
into a coffin and threw her into the
ocean where she gave birth to Perseus
Perseus finally has answers to how his
life came to be and now his only goal is
to kill Hades for Revenge IO explains to
him that if he kills the Kraken Hades
will be at his weakest which is his best
chance to kill him and so Perseus joins
the argosian soldiers on their Journey
to Find and kill the Kraken time passes
quickly and on the fourth day of their
Journey the chief in command asks
Perseus if he knows how to use a sword
he is given a little demonstration
before being attacked out of the blue
Perseus Falls at first but quickly
catches up and surprises everyone given
his natural born talent in sword
fighting he is told that he indeed has
the Flesh of a God then we are
introduced to perseus's stepfather the
king who is now living as a peasant in a
dark cave Hades approaches the man and
reveals that he is working in Zeus's
favor to gain his trust and strike him
at his lowest since the former King also
wants Zeus dead he is ready to do
anything to make Hades happy hence the
god of the underworld turns him into a
demon and sends him to kill Perseus
somewhere else as the soldiers take
shelter for the day Perseus wanders off
into the jungle and finds a sword and a
bunch of flying horses ooh they were
sent to him by his father Zeus who wants
his son to have a fair chance at winning
however Perseus refuses both The Sword
and the pure black horse sent for him
suddenly he hears a soldier cry for help
and discovers the demons sent by Hades
is here to kill everyone he leaps at
Perseus with a deadly strike but the
hero is fast to defend himself the
soldiers join him and overpower the
demon cutting off his left hand and
urging him to flee they quickly follow
him but have have to split into two
groups to look for him the demon
disappears but instead the soldiers are
attacked by a giant scorpion living
under the sand this movie is based on
real history a fierce battle ensues
ending the lives of many soldiers one
after another at one point Perseus is
almost stung but is saved at the right
time by IO just when the Scorpion dies
and they think that they have won they
are surrounded by many more even bigger
scorpions the soldiers get ready to
fight again and are surprised when the
giant creatures stop in their tracks one
of them points towards a figure standing
nearby who happens to be Jin they are
the creatures who were once humans but
are now charcoal placed in a human form
and bonded with black magic the
commander doesn't trust them but he
agrees to receive help for the night
suddenly Perseus falls to the ground
because of his injured arm which has
been infected by Hades Venom in his tent
at night the leader of the Jinn uses
Black Magic to heal the arm the soldiers
misjudge him which causes a Small Brawl
but the Gin explains that his kind has
been waiting for ages to see the gods
fall and Perseus is their best hope in
the morning they ride the Scorpions
through the desert and reach the garden
of stigia by evening Perseus finds out
this is the place where the Kraken
defeated the Titans they go deeper into
the deserted place to meet the stigian
witches who know the secret to kill
Kraken IO warns Perseus to be careful
and ask of the witches only what he
needs to know stigian witches please I
need to know do the ladies think that I
am sexy they go into a cave where they
see three gruesome witches one of them
carrying an eyeball that helps them all
see the smell of fresh human blood makes
them attack the soldiers but Perseus
gets a hold of their eyeball and uses it
as leverage to free his mates The
Witches then finally reveal that the
only way to kill Kraken is through the
Deep
Medusa long ago the god of the sea
Poseidon liked a beautiful Medusa and
took advantage of her she prayed to the
goddess Athena for help but instead the
goddess was repulsed by her hence Medusa
was cursed to never be seen by any
living creature anyone who gets a look
at her face will turn into stone
including Kraken not long after the
group sets off to the underworld to look
for the prison Medusa is in on their way
Perseus runs into his father Zeus who
offers him to come to heaven and live a
happy life Perseus refuses the offer but
accepts a gold coins Zeus gives him as a
parting gift in the following scene the
group is in front of the sea that leads
them to the Underworld the Jinn bribes
the fairy man using perseus's coin and
as a result they are taken right to the
Medusa's prison IO has to stay outside
because only men are allowed inside the
prison but she warns them that no man
has ever made it out as the group enters
the prison they immediately hear a
feminine chuckle
Perseus tells everyone to keep their
eyes down and guard up Suddenly arrows
begin flying their way hitting the
Commander in his chest and before they
know it they are being attacked by the
demon s Perseus almost falls into a pit
of fire but is able to save jyn and
himself at the right time this part
looked terrible in 3D in theaters I
remember it as they are looking for the
rest of the group Medusa troubles two of
the young soldiers both of them
mistakenly take a glance at her face
which costs them their lives next she
catches Jen and tries turning him into
stone but because of his black magic he
is able to attack her at one last time
before dying the commander takes this
opportunity to stab her tail before he
is also turned into stone finally taking
advantage of her weakened State Perseus
beheads her with his sword an anxious IO
sees Perseus come out with the bag of
Medusa's head and is ecstatic but her
happiness doesn't last long because she
is stabbed to death seconds later by
perseus's stepfather before dying I
gives Percy as the sword he was gifted
by Zeus he finally uses it to defeat the
demon and accepts the flying horse as
well at the same time in Olympus Hades
comes to Zeus to ask for permission to
unleash the kraken hoping that his
children will pray to him again Zeus
allows Hades to do as he pleases back in
Argos the people have formed a cult to
sacrifice the princess so the Kraken
takes her instead of them the massive
Beast is released and begins shaking the
city of Argos Zeus hurriedly asks his
brother to stop the chaos because he
thought the prayers would help him but
his children are instead scared Hades
laughs at his brother
claiming that he has been a fool and
that the people's fear is fueling him
subsequently the princess is hung by a
bridge as a sacrifice but the Beast
doesn't just take her as the people
imagined the humanoid bats are set free
to kill anyone they please the Kraken
emerges from the sea and is about to
attack the princess when Perseus arrives
and climbs up the bridge with Medusa's
head the massive turns to Stone and with
it Medusa and the princess also fall
into the sea before Perseus can do
anything Hades appears in front of him
in his weakest State Perseus uses his
magical sword to strike at his uncle
which sends the god back to the
underworld where he is locked for
eternity finally Perseus Saves The
Princess and brings her to the shore she
thanks him and Promises to serve the
nation as a competent Queen in the last
scene Zeus comes to meet his son
allowing him the choice to remain a
human for the rest of his life screw you
Dad the movie ends as he gives his son a
special gift by bringing IO back to life
oh thanks Dad subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching